Speaker 1: Last week after the forthcoming Roe v
Wade decision from the Supreme Court leaked, there
was immediately speculation about who did the
leaking now. Much of the speculation was really
in bad faith. It was right wingers arguing that
the real problem here is that there was a leak
rather than the fact that women's rights are going
to be potentially set back by decades, thanks to
a number of activist judges placed on the Supreme
Court by failed former President Donald Trump. So
the issue isn't actually the leaker, but the right
wanted to make the leaker the issue, and the right
immediately said, obviously, this is a left wing
leaker who wants to pressure justices to change
their votes to keep Roe v Wade by making them
fear for their lives. And the latter, you know,
followed from there. And as I said last week,
we don't know the political orientation of the
leaker. There are two at least equally plausible
explanations. One is the leaker is on the left,
the leaker is pro-choice. And the idea of the
leaker was, I'm going to leak this now so that
the justice is planning to vote to overturn Roe v
Wade, will be pressured and they will be harassed
and they might fear for their lives. And they'll
say, okay, okay, I'll keep Roe v Wade. Now,
these are appointments for life. Supreme Court
justices have great security. It's not super
likely that that is actually the case, but it is
a possibility. Just as likely is the opposite. And
again, we didn't know one way or the other, but
just as likely is the hypothesis that the leaker
is right wing. Why would a right winger leak the
decision? A right winger would leak the decision
to make sure that by making the expected votes
public, none of the justices that are at least
as of the February draft, planning to vote
to overturn Roe v Wade, change their minds.
Imagine that. I don't know. Kavanaugh was on the
overturn Roe side back in February when the draft
was written. But since is thinking, you know,
maybe I should maybe I should vote to keep it.
The idea would be a right winger leaks it to
put pressure on those justices not to change
their votes. Either one is possible, but now we
are actually getting more and more information
that the right wing leaker scenario is
the more probable one. Nina TOTENBERG,
who is a longtime Supreme Court reporter, says
actually the main theory now is that this was a
right wing clerk who leaked this. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: In covering the court since the early
days of Roe. How much has this leak rattled
the institution and the way it's viewed?
Well, the way it's viewed is insidious. Quick
And I think within the court itself, it's an
earthquake. There has never been a leak like this.
There have been minor little springs that have
emerged from the court of reports of a a tentative
vote or misbehavior by one justice back in the 50,
6070s. There were leaks, those kinds of leaks, but
never an entire draft of a majority opinion. That
has never, ever occurred before. And it can only,
in all likelihood, have come from a justice that
I think is less likely. Perhaps one of the clerks
and the leading leading theory is a conservative
clerk who was afraid that one of the conservatives
might be persuaded by Chief Justice Roberts and
to join in much more moderate opinion. And then
there's another theory that it was an outrage,
liberal cleric. But I think the only one that
makes sense is that it came from somebody who
was afraid that this majority might not hold,
that Chief Justice Roberts might persuade one
of the conservatives to come over to him.
Speaker 1: So this type of reporting is
increasingly pointing to a right winger.
Now, we may never know, but remember,
Ted Cruz and others were saying jail the
leaker. They were assuming it was a liberal
and they were saying, you got to jail them.
Ted Cruz actually went on Fox News and said
the leakers should be jailed. Remember, this.
Speaker 6: Reason it was leaked is some left
wing presumably law clerk wanted to put political
pressure on the five justices that presumably are
in the majority right now. They wanted to put
heat and they wanted to invoke politics to try
to get them to change their vote. And by the
way, if that left wing law clerk succeeds,
it will be the most grotesque politicization of
the Supreme Court in the history of our nation.
You mentioned an FBI investigation. I hope
there is a serious one. And I hope whoever is
responsible for this not only is fired instantly,
but is prosecuted and serves real jail time for
violating the confidences of the Supreme Court.
Speaker 1: And then the last real liberal,
by which I mean a right wing reactionary,
Tulsi Gabbard. She went on TV and also said,
we we've got to prosecute in jail. But what's
the crime, Tulsi? She didn't say to be heard.
Speaker 5: I think it's also critical
to point out that this leak sets a very,
very dangerous precedent for our Supreme Court
for three important reasons. Number one is,
first of all, this person is a thief who
stole this information, released it with a
very specific intent to try to incite protesters
and intimidate and pressure our Supreme Court
justices to make a political decision rather than
a decision that is based on the Constitution.
Number two, we have the fact that Supreme Court
is not in place to legislate from the bench.
People's representatives at the state level,
at the federal level are charged to make laws,
not the Supreme Court. The Supreme
Court needs to make decisions
based on the Constitution. And the Department of
Justice, lastly, needs to go and prosecute this
crime, which is exactly what it is, and make
an example out of the person who leaked this
information. Because our Supreme Court justices
cannot operate under the fear that they will
have partizan political activists in their house
intimidating and threatening their ability to do
their job per the Constitution.
Speaker 4: And there was.
Speaker 1: Do they still want them jailed if
it is a right winger? But more importantly,
will we ever actually find out who
did it? I don't know that we will.